eh bien bon jour dans cette leçon nous
allons voir une très très grande
variante de la sicilienne une variante
extrêmement agressive
c'est la chenille comme jean baptiste et
oui bonjour tu es fan donc une
sicilienne j'irai ancestrales et
indémodable
qui a qui a atteint une cote de
popularité immense quelques années ça
n'a pas vraiment chuté
maintenant il ya encore des très fortes
voire qui joue ça on peut citer radjabov
par exemple on peut citer les coquinous
ça souvent et je dirais que peut-être
chaque grand maître du top 30 mondial a
joué au moins une fois tu éclaires voilà
c'est une ouverture qui est vraiment à
la pointe
et dans la théorie donne plutôt
confiance au noir lors des grands
joueurs aussi déçu si nikos et kramnik
qu'il a beaucoup joué et crame n'est que
l'a rappelé à son compte
ça date un peu maintenant il ya une
dizaine d'années où il jouait ceci dit
je vais faire de manière systématique
c'est une ouverture qui est très
agressive c'est pour revendique le jeu
pour le gain avec les noirs je dirais
que les échecs
actuelles ont un peu évolué et
maintenant on cherche à ne pas perdre
avec les noirs ouais voilà donc on veut
pas forcément ça quand on le joue on
joue on joue pour des variantes
égalisatrice et on peut être le kram
nico si c'est reporté sur 4,5 pour avoir
des ventes un peu plus solide mais quand
on voit qu'un joueur comme l'écho joue
ça avec les noirs c'est une garantie
quand même parce que l'écho passe pas
forcément par une passoire
bien sûr quelques pas des points
voilà mais je dirais que c'est une arme
redoutable pour la contre attaque lâche
nikov alors on va voir ça tout de suite
cette arme de contre attaque qui est
déjà si les normes d'un tacle en plus
une arme de contre attaque
la variante schennikov l'on doit voir ça
tout de suite c'est le coup eux quatre
ces cinq classiques pour un sicilien de
4 c 5 bien sûr car il ya trois ans
l'avait laissé six typique des
ouvertures de type chef nikov le coup
car ici tout de suite sur toutes les
autres variantes des si ceux ci sont
d'autres armes de sicilienne calais c6
c'est typique des quatre normales pour
les blancs tu vois la thur lancement
décalé le kanak a toujours classique on
est ouvert le centre est là le coup car
il est si m6 tout de suite on commence à
annoncer la couleur on y est presque on
peut encore choisir de changer avec
cavani avec six cas va laisser les trois
logiques on sort le cavalier évidemment
et on défend l'option de 4 à noter que
le coût kalyev ci s'étant joué le coup
câble et c3 ici de protection empêche le
coup c 4 le fameux coup de dé taux
central voilà on force le carillonnement
ces trois blocs l'option ces deux blocs
ripe sion c2 et là le coup je fais ch
nico bien qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
le coup eux cinq extrêmement agressif
alors toujours pareil quand on est
agressif
il ya toujours des avantages non
l'avantagé évidemment c'est qu'on gagne
un temps sur le cavalier des cas depuis
ce qu'on le chasse et on met un pion au
centre mais en contrepartie jean
baptiste say say le problème c'est ici
quoi le problème c'est sur la colonne
des effectivement il ya des faiblesses
sur la case dessin qui a des faiblesses
sur la case d66 un problème pour le pion
17 qui est un pion arriérés pour encore
un bon petit bout de temps
voilà mal à sortir des saints qui est
impossible comme des pions centre ont
donc cessé l'idée pour les blancs
maintenant ça va être de compenser cette
petite perte de temps en temps au
développement pour essayer d'obtenir
davantage positionnés voilà bon mais les
noirs décide de chasser de cavaliers des
quatre directement c'est à dire que il
ya pas trop de casse pour qu'avec des
quatre on peut imaginer par exemple
cavaliers f3 mais revenir sur la case de
départ
et bien l'avantagent du coup eu 5 c'est
qu'on peut jouer ou va-t-on directement
couffo b4 fougue et qu'à tout de suite
on a libéré le fou clou le canal et ses
3 et la menace évidemment c'est de
prendre le pion 4 avec problème voilà
suite
alors si on surprotéger le pion aux
quatre avec le fou en d3 par exemple et
bien là on comprendrait tout de suite
l'idée est noir c'est de jouer des cinq
des caisses position magnifique c'est
superbe
voilà ce que la menace tout de suite
c'est par exemple de prendre b4 suivi de
pions prend 1,4 avec fourchette par
exemple oui hein aussi lors de quatre
des quatre qui attaquent le cavalier qui
est loué pour l'instant mais même son
petit cocon moitié la menace et regarde
et si les blancs prennent on peut
envisager de prendre de deux façons soit
du cavalier soi même de la dame pourquoi
pas parce que vos parents croient et
bloquée c'est souvent beaucoup
d'ailleurs de prendre la dame avec un
jeu facile on va dire pour une suite
donc il ya pas il ya plus de problème on
a résolu donc sur cinq
on n'a pas l'embarras du choix et aux
photos agressif
voilà il faut essayer d'exploiter au
mieux les faiblesses que les noirs
procédé à noter peut-être encore une
petite petite souriante sur mathis
calais 6 et le coup cavalière simple qui
est classique
alors là c'est c'est très très actif
pour les noirs des cinq tout de suite
parce que si les blancs prénoms des
scènes qu'évidemment il a à [ __ ] en
cavalier f5 avec là aussi une partie
facile pour mémoire oui vraiment une
position où les pièces noires sont très
bien développé donc c'est un jeu très
agréable pour le développement a pu
rallier les pasta blanc avec 5 donc pour
aussi d'aller à la casse des six il faut
occuper l'autre case qui permet d'y
accéder à savoir la classe b saint voy
la kabbale et db5 c'est le coût est plus
raisonnable le plus dynamique qu'à
valider cinq le plus même si quasiment
budget alors que les autres qu'on soit
inférieure will entre nous ça nous
laisse un gros coup mais en plus c'est
seul coup c'est quasiment le seul coup
voilà est par contre on contrôle la
casse des six la faiblesse donc toujours
pareil voilà dès qu'on est un peu
concentrés sur le sujet on a en a
vraiment on met l'accent sur le doigt
sur les faiblesses à douala
donc là effectivement on doit on ne doit
pas laisser les cavaliers venir en d6 on
peut le faire dans certaines variantes
mais c'est autre chose
oui oui on a tous des six voilà on n'a
pas très envie quand même avec ce qui
est relié qui viendrait pour ce
changement le plus fou de cases noires
on sait pas trop comment ça c'est la
dame après donc on joue des six messi
alors là il ya deux grandes variantes en
fait il n'y a rien là grandes marques
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui un oui et on
va en aura peut-être le temps de montrer
la deuxième ronde qui est un peu moins
joué mais qui se joue l'hymne en parler
un petit peu par les gros
on va on va revenir tout de suite il ya
le couffo g5
voilà on est second et ça c'est la
variante du tramway et le deuxième coup
c'est le coup cavaliers des 5 voilà on a
deux cavaliers ici avec une menace
directe c'était nécessaire
je me risque à se faire une fourchette
fléchettes donc en général il va falloir
que les noirs prénom dessin j'ai une
route un peu secondaire qu on verra tout
à l'heure donc ici fou g5 g5
alors on cloue le calice voilà il faut
savoir que pour traiter la case des
simples la case blanche en d5 et bien
toutes les pièces sont capables de le
faire y compris le foot clanwar alors
comment un fou de cases noires peut-il
jouer pour une place forte et ça il faut
le retenir parce que dans pleins
d'ouverture c'est pareil le fou de cases
noircies le fouquet opposé à la case
forte que l'on veut occuper peut se
développer en faisant pression sur un
cavalier un cavalier qui lui-même
contrôler cette case
alors quand un cavalier qui contrôlent
case blanche il est sur une liste noire
est donc dans le foot quasiment 200
jouets pour la classe des cinq
bizarrement c'est indirect mais on voit
bien que le câble et 6 louer ici ne
contrôle plus la case desseigne contre
le plus que virtuellement voilà c'est un
contrôle indirect contrôle indirect
voilà donc ici les noix en profitent
maintenant pour jouer le coup à six ah
oui ils sont obligés de le faire
maintenant parce que s'il ne faisait pas
bien frais fou prend 26 suivi de
cavaliers des cinq et on peut pas éviter
les cavaliers de venir danser 7
imaginons effectivement que les noirs
jouent par exemple il faut aux soldes
flottants à ce rythme on en fait la
catastrophe c'est une catastrophe
horrible fou prend 1,6 alors là en plus
on ne pourrait même pas faire un peu
même par un fils cause de cavaliers
prend des s'il allait prendre des six
échecs avec l'homme qui protège
évidemment mais si les noirs font depuis
on prend alors déjà c'est horrible parce
que le fou est très mal placé bah oui on
n'a pas sorti ici pour qu'il soit aussi
passif mais en plus après qu'elle ait
des 5 alors on voit sa position est
énorme pour le nascar et laissé 7 avec
fourchette
voilà si les noirs sont obligés de
refaire petit rock en plus pressants
c'est vraiment c'est pas bon pas bon pas
bon donc ils sont 18 à 6 voilà donc il
faut jouer absolument sur france 5 il
faut jouer le coup à six est impérative
donc alors si vous jouez avec le mans il
faut absolument jouer ce coup maintenant
et ne pas se trouver là il faut
comprendre le bon timing
on n'y a pas d'autres coups et c'est le
début du ressort c'est nikos car il ya 3
3 et la battant b5 et c5 voilà tout cela
pour les noirs avec l'idée le plomb est
tombée simple idée c'est de venir en b 4
avec fourchette tout simplement voilà on
menace déjà de gagner une pièce voilà en
plus on les blancs sont obligés quand
même considérer cette menace à sa juste
valeur et ça permet aussi ensuite
peut-être loire de développer le fou en
b 7 6 il faut pour attaquer le pion aux
4 on peut aussi envisager fou mais c est
peut-être ce atteindra voilà en tout cas
le pion bessin qui est souvent un très
bon pion pour essayer de déloger au
moins le cavalier c3 qui est un cavalier
qui contrôle le plus quatre coups
logique pour les blancs on va enlever
cette menace tout en accentuant la
pression
centrales et notamment la pression sur
le cavalier si ça valait le coup car les
200 logique
j'utilise la casse faible pour faire
pression sur le canal et m6
voilà donc il ya deux possibilités soit
en tout cas des cinq tout de suite soit
en fait vous prend à m6 on peut aussi
effectivement deuxième la possibilité
faire [ __ ] en epci ce qui est une qui
est une variante également très jouée
qui tourna alors ici voilà comment son
premier fils alors là on est obligé de
faire plus on prend puisque sur dame
prend y ait des cinq qui gagnera tempo
sur dan franck et les cinq gagnants de
temps sur la dame s'est passé pas moins
je reprends mon jour on prend du pays
alors là on est dans cette structure
typique de l'aser chlykov oui où on a
les deux pions doublé f6 f7 et
comme je sais plus qui disait mais c'est
très intéressant quand l'avantagent du
pion doublé c'est qu'on peut jouer deux
fois le même beaucoup plus jouer deux
fois le même mois tout à fait même
beaucoup et f5 est un très bon coup ici
plus tard pour les noirs pour essayer de
faire sauter le verrou avec les chances
du plan de 4 mais ce verrou ici en 4 est
vraiment le chaos qui tient la position
du koala les plus rapides sur le
catésien pourra à nouveau jouer le pion
à f5 pour contrôler le centre un peu
plus voilà une ouverture qui est très
dynamique
on peut être on peut regarder la
variante centimes à camélia et 0,5 pour
les noirs tout de suite voilà alors on
peut aussi jouer le coup fourré cède
tout de suite voilà on peut rêver
d'avoir le coup fourré la croyante de
novossibirsk qu' on ne va pas trop
présenté ici par lequel très proche
finalement réussi très proche et pas
forcément c'est un peu la même idée ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est l'idée
générale il ya des transpositions de
coûts de façon sûre ces trois pour les
blancs alors coup classique de lachenaie
qui cause l'idée du coup c'est 3 et
double un jeu contrôle des quatre donc
jean pêche lequel les c6 devenir en d4
et deux jours car surtout 2 lecavalier a
trois qui étaient hors jeu qui m'a
kiva qu'il va revenir au centre via ses
deux ou trois de ces deux baies 4d fois
voilà il était un des fois il va venir
en b 4 donc en tout cas sera bien placé
en c2 et il aura le choix en fonction
des circonstances
nous donnerons pas le pion au f5
tout de suite non alors ces trois c'est
une possibilité on peut regarder
peut-être à la base de ces trois notes
possibilités alors il ya les deux sortes
de sacrifices possibles
il faut faire soit ces femmes et on veut
la garder assez vite vous prendrez 5
alors qu'elle prend b5 avaler prendra
d'avoir des câbles hypron bis elle
promet cinq pions proches et ça rend fou
préserver 5 déjà deux pions pour la
pièce deux pions pour la pièce menace de
cavalli c6 voilà sur food et 7 qui est
le bon coup qu'ils le savaient bien fait
pions 3f saint ménas on prend un f5 et
ça fait trois pions pour la pièce ont
déjà ses possibilités c'est valider oui
chacun des deux camps va avoir des
arguments à faire valoir
alors à noter le piège quand même
classique vas-y c'est que si les noirs
se disent même attention je récupère une
pièce effectivement way damas cinq
échecs je fais par exemple madame d2 ou
c3 plutôt qu'ils y croient
hélas si je prends le fou évidemment
c'est l'erreur a pas faire pire a pas
fait à cause de la fourchette royal
alors la superbe fourchette même là le
tri dans le péché coran il faut parer
les chèques et non la dame étant prises
et la tour aussi on pourrait choisir
premier tour mais on va prendre la dame
ouais enfin comme tant qu'à faire
voilà voilà donc ça c'est à voter c'est
le piège classique
d'ouverture qu'il faut connaître bombay
si vous jouez des blitz ça peut arriver
souvent séparés vais même vous même des
bons joueurs peuvent tomber entre les
griffes 5.5 fou j'ai cette foulée cette
voie là on va pas forcément montré bon
pause rock et rock peut-elle être
champion voilà trois pions le plan pour
les blancs et bien pousser tirer comme
un malade les pions de l'ale d'âme parce
que ces sont des pions qui sont passés
liés facilier il faudra les faire dame
là bas au fond un contrôle bien le sens
donc on a des mains libres pour pousser
et puis les doigts avec la pièce de plus
vont essayer justement de valoriser leur
jeu dynamique dans une pièce de plus on
essaie de développer forcément un jeu de
pièces bien sûr et donc qu'on peut jouer
par exemple des choses comme petit rock
fou ou voilà qui on retire hoc eu quatre
ou cinq dames match 4 ou aussi bourget
lui dommage 4ème à assange deux
étrangers 8 chacun aura ses arguments
voilà donc on va pouvoir jouer un jeu de
pièces classiques ça c'est le sacrifice
d'abord cavaliers pro b 5 exactement
alors sur le coup f5
on peut aussi jouer [ __ ] en bessin fou
prend des cinq qui tangue un peu
différent voilà puis on prend 25 bon il
faut passer alors la référence aux
menaces et la grande partie la fameuse
partie effectivement qu'une partie qui
trie connu entre
shirov et kasparov ouais apprendre et
simple après un bep cinq cavaliers
prendre sa cavale et prendre des cinq
tours pareil la menace c'est en ces sept
à noter que si les noirs font la grande
dame à cinq échecs on peut encore leur
planter le fameux très simple b2 b3
c'est de ces droits par douala est sur
le départ en a blessé deux devant vous
au la fameuse le fameux trident voilà la
fameuse fourchette royal avec trident
donc la pire donc c'est le piège
classique évidemment donc pas là-dedans
évidemment donc on joue beaucoup tour à
4 par exemple
elle a aussi joué le coup pourra cette
fois que ça se joue aussi pour assad les
possibilités tout dans cette tour à
quatre et un coup bon tir élèves la tour
de la fourchette et en plus qui a une
menace sur le pion de 4 voilà l'idée
c'est qu'il faut enlever la fourchette
ici mais 3,4 mais évidemment on
n'empêche pas alors l'échec ne vaut pas
grand chose un suffirait de bouger le
roi en 17 c puis finalement de les
cavaliers sont pas si stable que ça
voilà si on fait un siècle de vie en 17
et il n'y a pas forcément de suite on a
pas l'option ducasse blanc a oui c'est
une position qui est un peu délicate
dans le rang 17 des rockets etc mais on
a une caisse de plus convaincant même
pièce de plus une grosse pièce de plus
on a la reprise de plus donc là on joue
le coup bk douala en prenant on protège
le pion de 4 voilà alors rejoint en
quarts autant mettre une pièce à la
défense du point 4
on va se dire attention mais si les
noirs prennent en d4
l'idée c'est que la dame ici en d1 va
attaquer la tour 1 c'est ça l'idée
aurait imaginons par exemple cavaler
premier 4 on ne prend pas de la tour
puisque cavale et d5 est en embuscade et
là on peut envisager de faire on peut
d'abord enlever le cavalier on peut
faire cavalier seul et c'est cette par
exemple alors par exemple c'est lucy
lucy voit là cavalier dc7 qu'elle est
nécessaire
voilà leur part elle aura bougé ensuite
on peut jouer quelque chose comme ses
trois à jouer c2 c3 avec la double idée
c'est que j'attaque la torah 4 et le
voilà et là on avait quatre voilà donc
il ya des tout de suite des points en
tout cas les blancs on sortent pas mal
de l'ouverture à huy après le sac s'est
fait souffler après la classe et pas mal
alors donc sur tours à 4 il faut jouer
b4 et vous bien caché donald quatre
dames h4 pour les noirs voilà
développement de la dame ici avec la
menace évidemment de prendre le pion aux
quatre de l'autre côté voilà et après
petit rock la pop rock logique on les
attend dans le corps g8 et puis on
s'aperçoit et attend que je perçois que
encore une fois belle et noir ont des
arguments qui sont bien différents de
ceux des blancs les blancs au veulent
pousser les pions de l'ale dame
vers la promotion il va les pousser mais
pour l'instant ils peuvent pas trop le
pion à être bloquée par la torah câble
tout de suite le pion b4 est bloqué par
les câbles et vaisselle mais c'est ça
peut être dans l'idée effectivement de
débloquer rapidement ses pions mais ça
va pas être facile de les avancer et
faire attention la menace imminente de
takrit commencé à voir un petit peu la
taxe chacun se sert du bon surtout qu'on
va vite aussi puis on prend 1,6 md des
possiblités concours h3 donc il va
falloir faire très attention à noter que
maintenant que la dame et d'orages 4
aussi sur un échec ans et 7 vous pourra
mettre le roi en des huit pour ne pas
bloquer le faut avant tout à fait donc
variante très intéressante là pour les
noirs si si on aime bien les l'attaqué
pour les blancs c'est une sacrée avoir
le coeur bien accroché un sacré mais
cette fois fort intéressante
donc il faut faire attention il faut
quand même connaître cette possibilité
alors alors sur sur mes cinq dont
convient de voir cette possibilité de
sacrifices alors non parce qu'on n'a pas
fini encore sur fou prend 1,26 g prend
m6 alors sur foot pro m6 voilà c'est fou
quand même facilement 6 g prend m6
maintenant l'autre suit le dessus dame
prend maintenant preuve si j'ai
progressisme et l'autre un doublon
apparemment d'autres textes
ah oui le corporal alors où suis je sais
pas
je lai voilà fou point m6 ici voilà vous
prend avec cg prend est-il on va finir
avec cette variante
je suis perdu oui on a perdu alors on va
y arriver on va y arriver à cliquer sur
la ligne voilà voilà son problème si ces
problèmes finissent je prends ici alizés
cinq tables et 5 c 3 alors parce que sur
f5 on a envisagé les deux sacrifices et
le coût normal quand même c'est c3 c3
voilà on va on avait bien expliqué
pourquoi seront joués ces trois là on va
se développer maintenant avec les noirs
avec le coup avec le coup g77 classique
donc là on revient effectivement un peu
d'art variante qu'on a
alors si on prenait cette fois ci le
pire en 2004 parce qu'on peut se
demander pourquoi le prix henri iv reste
en l'air alors cette fois ci on faisait
fou prend b5
alors on va le montrer oui il faut il
faut démontrer 530 viennois reprendre
près le pion aux 4 qui serait une faute
voilà alors
ici voilà je monte ma variante la rocade
fou prend b5 pendant ces 5 puis on prend
médias les 1er 5
alors on se rend compte d'abord qu'on
n'a plus tour à 4 mais surtout que la
menace cavaliers c7
ce serait maths en fait puisque après sa
série matt à cause du de la van dam des
quatre cavaliers ses sept rois régine on
décèle droit 4 coûtera clac où il a
peut-être motors en l'air mais on va y
aller c'est pour n'importe quoi là oui
c'est pas vous a montré le réseau de ma
toile adam g7 et là c'est matt le seul
coup c'est 5 et prend avec matt voilà
comme si c'est bien annoncé voilà donc
là c'est la petite différence c'est
qu'on a pris en tout cas donc on a
libéré cette diagonale donc cédé aux
naines blanches qui permet la dame de
fer mat
donc c'est pas c'est pas très bon de
toute façon alors je sais il faut de
façon générale il faut pas prendre en
quatre temps que le fouet suite n'a pas
bougé et qui bloque laure noualhat parce
qu'il ya des menaces de sacrifices alors
fou g7 est logique floue g7 food et 3,3
menace de prendre à f/5 alors là c'est
intéressant c'est quand un procès
classique pour contrer ces fous aux six
fois ci soit la voilà ce que surprend f5
de cavaliers tomberait voilà surtout on
prend 1,5 il suffit de prendre un des
cinq on peut pas prendre tout de suite
donc là au coup classique oui c'est
dommage c'est effectivement la
possibilité avec des menaces de type
l'idée c'est de procéder les noirs font
petit rock c'est ce qu'ils font là les
blancs pour être se dire mais attention
je peux prendre un f5
c'est important c'est une rente qu'il
faut connaître puisque sur flu prend
cavaliers way avec les blancs on peut
jouer f6 avec l'idée tout simplement
d'un proche 7 madras qui est le fruit
heureusement les noirs ou une défense et
là il ya quand même une défense c'est le
coup eux quatre voies la superbe avec
l'idée bien tu m'attaques le food g7
mais moi je t'attaque le foot est roi et
sur pion de pranger 7 qui est logique on
va être le simple tours 8
voilà dans une position très confortable
pour les pour les grands voilà sur dame
prend des scènes qui paraît bon en fait
tout simplement prendre tous les trois
avec et chacun m donc c'est une position
un peu un peu tendu qu'il faut connaître
évidemment mais
les noirs sont surtout bien il n'y a pas
de problème il faut faire attention aura
pas craqué sous la menace de meute tout
simplement jaffe donc on prend par f5
ont fait effectivement petit rock ça
c'est classique
voilà et la f4 c'est le moment parce que
là la menace de prendre 5 oui maintenant
c'est une menace effective et fait
vraiment attention parce qu'il ya plus
l'histoire de tours 8
absolument c'est plus pareil donc il
faut faire attention
donc la f40 bloc on bloque l'avancée il
alors on peut voir la suite mais sur ces
communes intéressant tour à tour je
pense qu'après tout radio on peut aussi
commencer à parler éventuellement des
plans respectifs ont validé pour les
pour les blancs c'est exploiter la
faiblesse trop de la colonne dès lors on
peut se réaliser 3 puis à un moment
donné il faudra aussi essayé d'enlever
ce pion f4 qui nous gêne pour être
cavaliers en étroit avec le coup j'ai
trois ce coup là on va on va voir on y
va et chalets c'est parti d'un coup j'ai
trois voire simplement à g iii vide et
je veux prendre en g 4 et puis reprend
pourquoi pas du tout voilà alors il faut
pas prendre avec les noirs évidemment
parce que sur coup franc j'ai trois ans
ferait h pranger 300 projets 3 mais on
peut le montrer
oui comme pranger trois ce serait une
erreur a construit un congé trois et on
va jouer crois j'ai deux très vite au
machin et ses maîtres matin une colonne
âge qui est très très pénibles pour les
noirs ici ça serait une grosse faute à
une très grosse faute donc il faut
surtout pas prendre
mais attention j'ai envie de te dire
jean baptiste mais si je prends pas avec
les normes des pères le pion avec quatre
oui alors on ont cédé fois que c'est pas
forcément si grave parce que ça l'hiver
la case de 5 mais là en plus on a une
ressource très intéressante pour ne pas
le perdre
encore oui c'est de jouer là tout ranger
huit tours j'ai vite
voilà donc là avec l'idée attention
vis-à-vis tour voilà retrait suicidaire
pour les blancs de prendre anges
henri iv parce qu'après la reprise est
bien le fou g7 est prêt à partir pour
faire une découverte porte elle nous
coûte le fou g7 dont pour apprendre
d'abord avec le pur ans le pion de 5
par contre on apprend 1,5 puis on prend
1,5
cavalier prend un f4 maintenant fou
prend ses trois pères le pion avec un
échec il faut penser 3 ou même fou aux
cinq qui gagnerait sans doute phocéenne
qui gagne qui risquent gagner le
le cavalier 4 qui est mal placé kiev
devant et j'ai deux équipes abrégée de
la fouge et 4 qui affirme la dame parce
qu'un fou g4 après c'est évidemment
parce qu'il ya une vie dans une main de
fourchette ici donc nous lie tous toutes
ces idées sont valables sur surtout chez
8,1 de toute façon donc voilà l'idée
d'un crash
voilà logique au rachat talent fou et
suite voilà donc avec l'idée maintenant
sur une prise lab simplement que je
souhaitais être exact n'est qu'une
menace autour d'alain d'où le courroux
du fou et 2 et maintenant c'est le
fameux bourges de saint-ours g5 et la
dame est attaqué donc là pas beaucoup de
cas on se rend compte que c'est une
variante qui est très dynamique pour les
noirs elle très très bonne pour les
noirs effectivement patron dynamique
dynamique en tout cas parce que les
blancs des arguments aussi un sac une
fois qu'ils vont laisser passer l'orage
et les noirs il ya beaucoup de choses en
prise au bout de sa ds3 la f3 voilà 4 5
et 5 et on parlait de tout deux fois f5
et bien voilà ce qui arrive alors la
menace pour des noirs c'est de jouer
évident fou prend qu'à valider cinq
c'est ça la vraie menace puisque sur
pions prendre les 5 qui a tout de suite
eu 4 qui peut être dans l'air par
exemple alors ça donnerait le pion à f k
s'adresse qu'à l'idée est qu'on sache de
laisser partir
depuis samedi une bonne idée faire
attention à ça donc j'ai prend 1,4 de la
part des blancs voilà je prends des
problèmes 4
il y prend un cadre sûr qu'à l'épreuve
4eme tout simplement fu panda 2 où tu en
es rétablissant l'équilibré matériel et
là bas c'est un bazar indescriptible
c'est un bazar il faut aimer les
variantes tendue c'est typique de la
cheville nicolas quand je sais avec les
noirs il faut il faut être prêt à avoir
ce genre de position si vous aimez les
positions où il y en a partout et bien
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire si
vous n'aimez pas ça avec les blancs en
revanche
eh bien vous avez une alternative c'est
non pas fou prend f6 mes cavaliers des 5
qu'est la deuxième variante de notre
leçon stéphane alors on va effectivement
revenir maintenant alors sur voilà
qu'une variante quand même beaucoup plus
calmes qu'à valider cinq lui 9e coup en
grand kallé des cinq qui est l'autre
variante plutôt que vous prendrez les
piscines voilà une variante un peu plus
zen je dirais ou où les noirs sont
certes moins mis en difficulté mais où
il est blanc quand même ne faut pas
sauter à la gorge tout de suite quand
même alors on va voir après alors il
faut 7 kg ginette voilà alors les blancs
vous prendre du foie là on se sépare de
fou on donne la part de flou on est
d'accord mais le plus important c'est de
maintenir le cavalier centrale en d5
comment la vie ont comme on l'a dit tout
à l'heure c'est qu'ils viennent c'est le
fou de caisse noire qui élimine le
défenseur de la casse des six mois la
foule des grands jours où tout prend
même s'il faut ensuite on recycle le
cavalier c'est une manoeuvre que
maintenant on connaît bien vous voyez
qu'on retrouve ça dans toutes les
variantes de l'anus nikos est là faut
jouer très vite aussi les noirs on va
jouer le petit rhum il va falloir jouer
très vite aussi pour le contrôle de la
caisse des cinq ça va toujours tourné
autour des centres me compte toujours
petit rôle clé rock cavaliers ces deux
cas la laisser deux voies la fouge et 5
fu g5 un coup deux idées contrôler la
case de 3 pour éventuellement à un
moment donné abc le cam allez viens en
trois pour protéger son collègue il
pourra être le challenge est peut-être
théâtre au bon moment le terrain mais
surtout on veut enlever le fou de la
casaque 6 puisque notre île et ses
cavaliers cette voie là on veut aussi
jouer cavalier 7 pour attaquer la scène
mais éviter ces riens coup pour échanger
des cavaliers l'un ou l'autre mais sans
casser d'oeufs rock parce qu'on peut
casser l'europe quand on a encore le fou
de cases noires à l'intérieur est ce
parce que les cases noires sont faits
mais le foot 15 noir est là pour veiller
si on teste l'europe qu'on n'a pas le
fou de cases noires c'est la grosse
différence alors là attention ça va
quand même mal se passer exactement
alors là il ya deux grandes variantes
pour les blancs alors il ya le coup à
quatre il ya le coup à 4 qui est qui moi
me paraît très bon hein c'est un coup on
essaye de deux mètres à la pression sur
le duo de pions noirs comme ça un petit
peu affaiblie alors évidemment c'est le
problème des noirs dans cette variante
ils ont joué à 6b 5 tonnes gagnant du
temps bien sûr mais c'est aussi une
cible avec cécile ça va être même la
cible principale pour les blancs ses 7,7
cette faiblesse là qui ont essayé
d'attaquer de mines et on voit bien que
le fouet fonds est très bien placé pour
ça puisqu'ils tablent aussi sur ce duo
donc il n'a pas trop le choix sur 1 4 il
ya une autre variante possible qu'on va
comme a aussi jeté en rajoute un petit
coup d'oeil avant ch4 voilà qui tient
aux curieux a priori on se disait
attention mais je peux prendre 24 alors
attention piège puisque si les noirs
prennent le simple coût d'un match 4
mais on voit bien que dame ici aidé par
la tour menace le fond qui s'il s'en va
laisse faire dame prend h7 mat
voilà donc sais c'est pas possible pour
les noirs la d'obtenir donc il faut pas
prendre le curage alors la question se
s'il est si les noirs ne prennent pas le
pion le pion aux quatre alors je vais me
[ __ ] au monde
parce qu'ils ligne ici voilà h4h 4 ici
olala problème en alors sur h4 voilà
évidemment on joue le kung fu à chis hcr
à quoi a servi donc le coup h4 eh bien
on sait que pour jouer f5 une deuxième
fois les noirs préféré je le jouais avec
l'aide du pion g6 pascal en jour h5 dans
ces cas là on jouait à chiens qui on
aurait une
bien belle colonnes pour pouvoir
attaquer sur le petit road baignoire
mais sur l'ansé à l'idée c'est de
d'empêcher ce con tre jeu comme ça c'est
énorme et ça bloque un peu le roi blanc
tu as montré le coup hk qui a aussi une
autre possibilité au 13e coup à la place
du coup h4 du coup à quatre c'est le
coup j'ai trois aussi qui est tout à
fait intéressant ça fait pour contrôler
encore un peu plus toute la diagonale
qui nous intéresse alors des données
intéressantes puisqu'on sait que le pion
eu 4 est amené à partie alors on sait
que quand on va partir en f5 et bien on
aura une grande diagonale très
intéressante pour être fou c'est juste
moi là c'est une variante qui est qui
est jouable aussi le le thème est à peu
près le même toute façon mais voilà
alors à 4 est quand même très
intéressant en notre sens puisque alors
on voit la grande variante à 4 qui est
assez classique aussi peuvent se
ressemblent voilà il faut étudier tout
je me rends à 4 tours prend 1,4 voilà il
aa 5 à 5 pour enlever le pion de sa case
un oui mais un peu fébrile en aura 6 et
maintenant l'idée d'avoir fait sauter
ses pions b5 c'est de pouvoir enfin
développer le foot et 4 le fou en c4
pour qu'ils puissent contrôler la casse
des 5 et puis en étant gêné la poussée
du pion f2 noir voilà c'est la place sur
tous âges cas chez f5 découverte du
cavalier avec le footy fraîcheur qui
appuient la tour à tour entreprises donc
ça retarde sa le fou très bien passé en
c4 ils compteront aussi la casse des
cinq bien sûr donc voilà l'idée du coup
du coup à 4 tours b 8 tours et 8 contres
jeu sur le plan b 2 évidemment je contre
attaque sur le pion en maintenant levé 2
qui ne peut rien il suffit de jouer b3
il est protégé par le fou donc ça c'est
assez classique et maintenant comme
d'habitude chacun des deux camps va
faire valoir ses arguments sur les noirs
vont essayer de jouer f5 et les blancs
vont essayer de profiter des
affaiblissements généraux
dames alors après 3h huit normales ce
qu'on veut jouer f5 ce petit rock petit
rock g6 et on comprend maintenant la
lutte qui va avoir lieu dans cette
position après f5 et bien les noirs vont
avoir des pions dynamique qui vont
essayer de pousser sur les droits et
puis les blancs quant à eux ils ont des
possibilités intéressantes sur les
derniers temps de mettre la pression sur
le pion à cinq portes est enlevé le
cavalier des 5 pour mettre le fou à la
place de faire pression sur le cavalier
ses six mètres le fou on prend soin ou
tard envisagée mais aussi les quatre
dans les noirs se seront affaiblies sur
les droits et bien trois se permettre ce
coupé quatre qui c'est vrai enlève la
faiblesse à 5 baignoire mais commence à
ouvrir le jeu et laisse les noirs avec
des affaiblissements un petit peu
pénible mais sur les plus criants
passion à la musique typiquement ses
fans c'est une ouverture à double
tranchant que les noirs peuvent choisir
s'ils veulent un peu mettre le bazar sur
l'échiquier mettre le feu comme comme
dit shirov et comme l'a écrit shirov en
tout cas cette variante est quand même
avec cavaliers des cinq un peu plus
calme que fou prend un f6 un peu plus
qu'un que vous pourrez y voilà mais en
tout cas c'est une ouverture sécu
positionnelle beaucoup plus positionnée
crs des 5 et bien d'une wii des bleus
pour la part des blancs à l'autre
variante des shows des belles parties
avec les plans là dessus retrouvez dans
les bases de données avec ce code ce
fameux b33 avec tout un tas de très
belles paroles c'est marrant tout y'a
quand même souvent des victoires d'un
côté ou l'autre il faut aimer ça faut
aimer le marquer le point pour marquer
le point avec les blancs avec les noirs
on est risque voilà si on veut marquer
des points mais le blanc c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce qu'on sait que ça va être
très tendu et avec classe et un
déséquilibre immédiat donc
donc c'est vraiment une variante qui
quand vous conseille vraiment de jouer
si vous êtes attaquant avec les noirs
c'est vraiment la variante fétiche et
avec les blancs faut pas hésiter à
entrer dans toutes les possibilités
sacrifices qu'on a vu c'est assez riche
aussi le côté blanc ayant beaucoup de
choix pour une chose voilà c'est avec
les noirs faut être prêt à connaître
beaucoup de variantes atteint exactement
les blancs plus la possibilité de
choisir de sélectionner la seule
variante qu'il veut jouer pour les noirs
il faut connaître quand même et du panel
panoplie de variantes toutes aussi
différentes les unes que les autres
eh bien merci jean baptiste derrien
stephano va bientôt on va